the highly classified military documents
leak that sent shock waves through the
Pentagon Jack text Sarah the
Massachusetts Air National Guardsman
suspected or arrested of Suspicion of
the Intel leak faced a judge for the
first time Friday he was charged with
two counts under the Espionage Act the
21 year old could face up to 15 years in
prison his arrest and the league have
renewed scrutiny over security
clearances now the Pentagon is
rethinking who should have access to top
secret files Willie James Inman reports
from Washington Willie good morning
hey there Michelle good morning the
Biden Administration is looking into
changing who has access to the nation's
most highly classified information
following a leak that went undetected
for months
a young Air National Guardsman accused
of leaking classified documents online
appeared before a judge in federal court
Friday to hear the charges against him
21-year-old Jack texera was arrested on
Thursday in Massachusetts in a dramatic
scene outside his mother's home he is
now being charged with Espionage Act
violations for allegedly taking and
transmitting classified documents if
this is not just about taking home
documents that is of course itself
illegal but this is about the
transmission both the unlawful retention
and the transmission of the documents
texera allegedly posted the materials in
a private chat on Discord a site popular
with Gamers the documents were
apparently there for months and
circulated online before investigators
discovered the leak the breach-led
President Biden to order the military
and intelligence Community to secure and
limit access to sensitive documents I've
instructed the
they get to the root of
why he had access in the first place
number one and number two to focus
extensively on the extent to which it
all occurred and that's going on right
now Federal prosecutors said in the
court filing texera supported cyber
defense operations Former Defense
secretary Mark esper questions why the
young Air National Guardsmen had access
to highly classified documents no I I
cannot think of a compelling reason and
I assume uh secretary Austin and
chairman The Joint Chiefs Miller are
probably asking those same questions
speaker Kevin McCarthy blamed the Biden
Administration for the leak and promised
congressional action something that one
Democrat on the house intelligence
committee pushed back on these things
happen under all presidents and so if
you want to score political points fines
but let's really focus on the problem
here which is an Institutional problem
not a partisan problem
President Biden also said he couldn't
predict how long the investigation into
the leak would take but he says he
thinks the administration will get to
the bottom of it quicker than
anticipated meanwhile teixera is in
custody at least until his detention
hearing which takes place on Wednesday
Jeff
okay Willie thank you